allora fammi fare un intro così lei poi
fa la intro e poi farò una chiusa i
ragazzi mi chiama oggi signor gatto che
qui presente confermo perché voleva fare
un gioco in coop cenno ai data non è in
coppa e uno verso uno e speriamo oggi ci
sfidiamo ad un gioco che ha un budget in
impossibile da mantenere
c'è da da sopportare su 10 93 centesimi
e sapete che io ho speso molti di più
per giochi molto più brutti però la
recensione molto positiva lo vedo molto
bello uscito da poco 360 uno scopo arena
grazie signor gatto che vi fa scoprire
vigore possiamo cominciare a lor signori
atto dietro il giorno bellissimo lo vivo
vi guardo il nome del giocatore e come
io mi chiamo ballerina non è ballerina
va bene io lascerei guardi non lo cambio
di una virgola nome ebel ballerina
eccolo signor gatto join the game
poi si spara a di fan 360 speculativa il
luogo bravissimo sempre me stesso per
lui è bravo e bellissimo sa se io premo
il tasto adesso non sia un'icona che di
oscura all'obiettivo esatto dai si
impegni signor dato s'impegni simo è ma
io ho passato i miei 12 anni in modo
molto molto brutto non vorrebbe saperlo
come cercato solo qui e sono qua sono
qua si deve deve trovare la sua
coordinazione una questione di chakra
deve trovare la sua coordinazione in
modo che giri e funziona c'è giro così
tanto veloce bravo bravo bravissimo
audio per che cos'è perché le 93
centesimi cosa si vuole immaginare a mi
spieghi e vabbè ma che bello lo ha fatto
benissimo spara molto dritto e quello
del file affatto pra e l'ho fatto
proprio bene dovrà vedere il mio video
sono proprio bravo diminuisco un po
tratto se ha notato il salto è
ricaricabile cioè non può saltare sempre
alta unito a ogni tot fatto bene
poveri noi mamma mia
perché a scuola tutto il corpo cosa
faccio perché ne ho fatti 800 li di giri
ama quindi se io faccio più di un mese
posso sparare quando mi teoria sì però
con una mira dubbiosa
grazie comunque non so se ha notato
perché da lei non si può vedere perché
in prima persona
abbiamo da entrambi dei dei parastinchi
e para ginocchia di un certo livello ne
arriva una fondina per la pistola una
fucina per l'api mi faccia riapprezzare
un secondo che qua ho pagato 99
centesimi mica fuffa molto bello vorrei
vedere anche in una versione guardi sta
roba qua anche se sarebbe un po da
vomito
la miseria è una roulette russa
mamma mia attenzione il recupero del
recupero ma perché scelte già si
festeggia tre non avevo visto tra
l'altro va bene non importa è una mappa
fatta veramente malissimo mannaia grazie
mamma mia che schifo
non posso competere dopo mi è caduto a
peso morto si è materializzato
c'è ancora tempo signoria il 35 secondi
faccia a faccia c'è tempo benghi per
watt rettifiche dell'orecchio che preso
paura il pareggio
il pareggio non è detto venti secondi
tensione a 55 non l'ho persa però buona
come prima parte molto anche molto
carino molto simpatico poco dispendioso
tutto giusto lo capisco io sono molto
preso di leggere anche le recensioni
dopo thor cravatta ma barche lisci
questa ex killer o al volante
ecco bravo signor gatto stavolta non la
risparmio perché prima dovevo provare ad
apprezzare il personaggio adesso no ma
dice a giocarci giocava ai tempi mv 2
quando c era lei un sol quindi non
è su console si fanno le fanno molto
meglio soprattutto certo apro palco cosa
molto intelligente da provare vediamo se
c'è il supporto joystick non sa quanto
lento
che bello non ci si può moglie non hanno
messo il supporto di movimento perché
dobbiamo stare fermo allora mi devo
correre con la tastiera e girarmi col
joystick e veramente brutta la faccenda
mamma mia che brutta rassicurato pippa
un anziano ormai a ma la chicca joystick
non riesco a farla va bene lo tolgo è
stato molto divertente dunque per però è
simpatico
no non ho sparato no che non è possibile
se annotato in stack ma sì che ho girato
girato lei non vede perché gira troppo
gira dalla parte opposta
no dicevo decisioni mlg li mettono loro
stessi si e non avevo sentito io che non
è che monta nel vivo visto montano loro
video vi faranno una best of immaginate
serata ci sta registrando c'è qualcun
altro quello del server ma ho cercato
non me l'aspettavo io lo so lo sfidato
perché volevo un pippone e devo scendere
un po la la skill mannaia qui sarebbe
bello se potessi fare altre cose tipo
switch aree l'arma anche se l'economia
andrò là shot altrove le cose ma aia che
mai dove sono qui signor gatto io mi sto
impegnando veramente poco c'è nel senso
benissimo r
niente da dire di si può fare
nient'altro però sono contento che mi
aveva fatto spenderesti 99 centesimi
l'amicizia si vedono da questo e da
queste piccole cose insomma che
dividiamo la parte ne ha fatti spendere
1000 di setup e il 90 no higher se lo
ricordi sempre questo modo assolutamente
impresso nella mente io stavo sparando
la cosa sopra di lei mano
fa niente questo mannaia ma che male 64
quanto mancano 56 secondi è difficile
recuperare va dove dove sale due sale
dove lui sale un vecchio eccolo no ho
girato ho sbagliato ad altro che a roma
è questa che non cecchino porca vacca
ma io sto guardando il cecchino però era
per distrarla
dopo dai tre secondi non recupero roma i
due colpe o all 88 e finisce beve 8 a 8
p 8 così è il cap del delle killer 8 va
bene non lo so deve fare la pella la
bella addirittura va bene va bene ok
signor gatto sono qui dove ha dato
questo non vuol dire però capisco allora
non mi piace quando giro tanto non
funziona la faccenda ma se giri
lentissimo non te lo dà neanche a site
lodati si trova con joystick noto remote
roba non mi prende si può cacciare in
aria notato adesso che cosa dovrebbe
servire
non lo so però ci si accovaccia e figo
il coraggio shot è l'unica cosa che può
cambiare rispetto allo shoot normale
inter 60 la domanda che le voglio porre
le molto semplice come ha fatto a
scoprire questo gioco chi gliel'ha
consigliato stavo guardando dal mio
spacciatore di giochi free nel cielo
allo spacciatore giochi free è una
specie questo era bellissimo questo era
veramente bello però lei o facendo
parlare per distrarmi e si è la tattica
che funziona anche quando giochi sulla
new 2 e quando finiamo questa partita io
a rifare un
in una rapida lettura delle recensioni
giusto per capire ai astoria in testa mi
sa che lei vince stavolta è molto forte
reso bene sta lasciando vincere no non è
vero non sono mai stato bravissimo nei
minigiochi dove si sparino le persone
dove eccolo là aspetti e niente
veramente forte oggi l'angola audio
ripresa per il culo a che mi sto
impegnando rosso più le dita non si
prende fi free con la pensa che si ci si
impegna sul 360 anzi generazioni di
bambini sono cresciute così io compreso
ma perché ballerina cigarette altro in
italiano non tradotto dal trono ma non è
che mi chiamo io ballerina su steam non
mi ricordano applichiamo fa dj bo perché
la ballerina da noi qua mi sono
impegnato moltissimo stanza sul
ginocchio e niente la supremazia dice
tutto che sfiga l'ultima che potevo
spararla va bene va bene o tu piacere
stato piacere anche per me la supremazia
schiacciante non si può far niente più
di così non potevo fare i pro vinto di
ping
ho bisogno di leggere le descrive
recensioni cioè giocato per un'ora quasi
non so come ha fatto a giocarci un ora e
l'altro ottimo gioco con ottime
potenzialità giustamente sottoscrivono e
niente come non dare ragione a questi
ragazzi
va bene per me signor gatto e quanto e
sono contentissimo e altra roba per
carità melodika anno vedo l'ora di
provare un altro gioco simile da
registrare per altre otto ore
assolutamente si alza in realtà akin
live magari se la vetrina delle ore
filate proprio allora io la ringrazio
spero che gli sia piaciuto ragazzi e un
saluto al signor gatto il canale ve lo
lascio in descrizione se non siete
questi scrivete non ci vediamo a un
persone uno scopo da ragazzi
[Musica]